I'm born
and raised in Brooklyn,
so I could tell you're not
from here but you fit in well.
Thank you so much.
I'm telling you, dude,
like when you order a coffee,
you just order the coffee.
You don't talk about
the integrity of the bean.
No. I'm like, "Give me
that latte, straight up."
Yeah.
You're from Ridgewood, right?
Ridgewood-Bushwick
borderline, yeah.
Why are you so shady?
It's not about shady.
It's when Mayor Bloomberg
was the mayor,
he changed the borderlines.
I was born in Brooklyn,
made it Queens,
so now I have a identity crisis.
So you know what it feels like
when the border crosses you.
See?
What's up, everybody.
Welcome to Stupid Questions
with Chris Distefano.
I'm here with my boy,
Arturo Castro,
who's got a new show
coming out on Comedy Central,
called Alternatino.
Just rolls off the tongue,
really. I like it.
What would you rather go
without, sex or alcohol?
Alcohol.
Alcohol, you're good?
Yeah, yeah, I-
You could drink no booze?
I'm just a social drinker, man.
Right.
And just, like, social,
every day, before noon.
You need to have sex.
Not even,
I just need to procreate
at some point, you know.
Absolutely.
Dude, I got a daughter.
Yeah? You know what?
My daughter is a Latina.
Awesome. What about that?
Watch Alternatino. There you go.
Yeah. Your daughter
is my main demographic.
She's Puerto Rican.
I'm Guatemalan, so we-
So is that ...
What's the difference?
I'm kidding.
It happens,
and everybody at a party
that's ever been to Peru
once in their life,
they're like,
"Bruh, I've been to Peru."
I'm like, "How was it?
I've never been."
All right,
next stupid question.
If you were ever to get
arrested, God forbid-
God forbid.
... what would your
family assume your crime was?
Probably got in a fight
with a clown.
Yeah? Yeah.
Are you scared of clowns, dude?
Yeah, they freak me out, bro.
Dude, they freak me out.
I admire all people
in the clown industry,
I'm just saying I had a clown,
when I was seven years old,
he smelled like booze.
Crispino payaso,
Okay. What? Is that a dish?
Payaso means clown.
Crispino payaso, to me,
just sounds delicious.
Christina Palatzzio.
It sounds like a girl
I would go on a date with
and then her father be like,
"If you touch my daughter ... "
Christina Palatzzio
over there.
Her father's the kind of guy,
he just walk on the treadmill
with sunglasses on.
Here's an idea,
would you rather be a guy
who's known to drink his own pee
or go on romantic dates
with his relatives?
What would you rather be?
I am drinking my own pee now.
Well, actually, no.
Truth be told,
you're drinking my pee.
Thanks. At what cousin
do you think it's okay,
I'll marry them and just deal
with the consequences?
What brings down the risk?
I think it ...
once you get to the second
cousin, you're good to go.
What if your first cousin's
a smoke show?
No, I rather would
drink my own pee.
Yeah? Yeah.
You know what I like about you,
I've been talking to you
for a little while,
you walk past me on the street,
I'd be like,
"I hate that guy
because of his hat,"
but now I like you a lot.
You got-
The amount of times
that people have called me
shitty Bruno Mars
on the street ...
Shitty Bruno Mars.
All right, here's a question.
All right. Okay?
Would you rather fart
every time you laughed
or would you rather
go heh-heh every time
somebody said
something depressing?
I don't mind farting
or whatever.
Probably fart every time
I laugh now.
As I get older,
I can't keep anything in.
I come from a family
of perfumers
so it smells real nice.
Yeah, but farting
in your house was dangerous
if your Mom had all
those chemicals growing up,
because the whole thing
would go up in flames.
Yeah, because
that's how it works.
Yo, cuz-
There's no spark involved.
Listen, I don't know
how to do ...
I'm not good with gas.
I do electric.
All right, did you have
a good time on Stupid Questions?
Awesome time, bro.
Dude, I wanted
to get you a gift.
Okay, so the first thing
I got you,
because you're Latino-
Yeah, I am.
... so I got you a soccer ball,
but it says England on it-
Wow. ... because ...
Because that's stupid.
But I just thought, you know,
England's a ...
it's a nice country.
Thank you so much.
And then also, because you're
on Narcos and you're from ...
you know,
I just got you a kilo of ...
that's actually
pure cocaine, so-
Look, I'm Maradona.
I'm Chris Distefano,
this has been Arturo Castro,
and we've had a good time,
and you're going to watch,
when it comes out
pretty soon, Alternatino.
Yes!
Alternatino! Yo soy
Christopher. Thank you.
Yo soy Arturo Castro.